ricardo buenas noches para ustedes y
cuáles son los puntos principales de
esta cumbre de jóvenes se para la 26
buenas noches y muchísimas gracias por
la invitación los temas son tres y se
resumen con las tres es el carbono los
carros y el cash que el dinero no
primero todavía tenemos muchas emisiones
de co2 todavía tenemos muchos países que
no se han comprometido hacia la
descarbonización antes del 2010 en 2050
como lo está mandando la ciencia segundo
todavía tenemos muy poca acción en
sectores claves hacia la
descarbonización por ejemplo en el
sector transporte sobre todo en
latinoamérica baja en inversiones en
transporte público y bajo en inversión
en este sentido y tercero estamos
esperando el sentido del financiamiento
los países desarrollados se
comprometieron a dar más de 100 mil
millones de dólares anualmente para que
nosotros los países vulnerables los
países latinoamericanos podamos
descarbonizar de manera efectiva y de
alguna manera adaptarnos a los efectos
del cambio climático entonces qué es lo
que queremos nosotros los jóvenes acción
no queremos más palabras no queremos más
discursos queremos realmente compromisos
de lo que viene siendo el problema y el
desafío más grande que ha enfrentado la
humanidad el tema del cambio climático
bueno y por qué la importancia destacó y
16 cómo influirá el documento final que
ustedes se van a sacar en las
negociaciones climáticas de la cob 26
desde el domingo
pues nos estamos reuniendo a miles de
jóvenes de todas partes del mundo en
plasmar cosas que consideramos son
bastante pragmáticas bastante acertadas
nos estamos basando enteramente en la
ciencia en lo que nos dicen los
científicos y al final del día son las
vidas de los jóvenes quienes van a estar
más afectadas por el tema del cambio
climático no entonces para nosotros no
es una cuestión de ganar votos son una
cuestión de vernos bien ante las
próximas elecciones etcétera etcétera
para nosotros es cuestión de vida y
muerte sinceramente entonces es lo que
se debe hacer es muy claro la ciencia ya
lo establecido y nosotros simplemente
estamos haciendo un eco que buscamos que
se traduzca y se plasme ante nuestros
dirigentes ante el 26 esta conferencia
de las partes de las naciones unidas en
las cuales reiteró buscamos acción
buscamos compromisos reales y buscamos
que todos los países estén a bordo
porque esto es algo que incide mucho más
en la juventud más que en cualquier otro
grupo de la sociedad